Wesley you're playing against Prague
today what can we expect from today's
matchup yeah I'm very excited I mean I'm
not sure what Prague is thinking or what
he said but uh
I I think it's gonna be an exciting
matchup probably the most important
things in the match are the openings
whoever whoever gets good position up
though things can win this match for
sure
and also time management because Frank's
very tricky I mean he's been playing
several different openings here with
both colors if I get the quotations I'm
comfortable in if I don't get the game
to game against
the nympho when I was almost lost with
white after 10 moves then I should be
okay it's gonna be it's going to be
interesting I mean Prague did very well
in Miami
uh here it doesn't seem he's in as great
form but it's still very strong he's
very good in this format I'm very
excited because I haven't really played
Prague that much I think I only played
him one over the board
or two over the board Blitz Games on
India and I played in the Olympia of
course
where he played like incredibly strong
and I just you know I say a big shout
out and congratulations to the young
Indian team for the bronze medal which
could have been higher
but uh anyway I'm very excited for today
I mean I have won my first match
yesterday against Arjun and hopefully
today this time we look forward to a big
fight all the best